what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are covering Hal Jordan and
the Green Lantern core and this is like
the next-to-last story arc if if the
solicitations are to be believed then
basically Hal Jordan the Green Lantern
Corps will and at issue number 50 I
think Green Lantern's is ending it the
same issue and they're both gonna
combine what they're gonna do with the
rest of the titles I don't really know
but for some reason DC has an affinity
for the number 52 right it was like new
52 they have 52 universes when new v2 2
kicked off all the issues ran for 52
issues until DC rebirth happened DC
loves the number 52 it's like the number
7 from Harry Potter
but anyway what this does is this
initially picks up with well really with
the dark stars now the whole idea of the
of the dark stars the the basis behind
them is that in the early 1990s round 9
tiny - I think it was DC was trying to
find a way to reinvigorate the interest
and the Green Lantern stories because
remember we talked about this and Howard
and explained from you know two years
ago whenever it was but Hal Jordan
despite the fact that he alongside Barry
Allen had helped to reinvigorate
interest in comic books in the 1950s he
basically dropped off in popularity
relatively fast like within 10 years he
was not very popular at all and in fact
he was a backup feature in the flash for
a while and so before DC had the idea to
kill him off and to I guess to get rid
of Hal Jordan to basically ride him out
with the whole event of Emerald Twilight
one of the things they did was create
the dark stars and the dark stars were
gonna be this sort of like new course so
think of it as akin to what Geoff Johns
did with all the lantern course before
Geoff Johns and they were basically
created by the group called the
controllers we'll talk a little about
the controllers here in a second but
back then in the 90s the controllers
were just like an offshoot of the
guardians of the universe they were just
they were all mountains at one point but
they had just gone a different direction
they become a lot more reclusive and a
lot more extreme and heavy-handed in
terms of how they believed the order of
the universe should be governed instead
of having the Green Lantern's as a
police force as a peacekeeping force the
dark stars were really extremists in a
lot of ways now of course this
eventually sort of began to fall to the
wayside after the events of Emerald
Twilight and of course DC started going
into new crises with Infinite Crisis and
Final Crisis and so on and so forth but
the return of the dark stars here in DC
rebirth what Vin de T is doing is is
making them a little more extreme and
simply saying that they have taken up
this mantle by way of the controller's
yet again the difference is that where
the dark stars used to operate under the
control of the controllers now they
operate independently they basically use
the
controllers for their own ends
harnessing their psychic powers and then
functioning as their own core more or
less and instead of being like the Green
Lantern's where they function and more
of a peacekeeping capacity they're
basically all like the Punisher they
just kill everyone in this instance what
had happened is tomar - who was formerly
a Green Lantern had defected to the dark
stars and then taken over the leadership
of the team now the reason why this
matters is because when he takes out
gold face who was basically a background
guy he's like a seal s level villain but
he had killed tomar ray during Infinite
Crisis I think it was and so tomar ray
of course was the father of tomar - and
that's why - amar - kills gold face
because he basically says you are going
to die for the crime that you committed
and that's the nature of the dark stars
that is it's extreme and it's hardcore
and so when Howerton arrives on the
scene and starts going through and
basically analyzing the bones of gold
face he essentially realizes look this
was done by a dark start and that's what
really turns his attention here because
what it means is the dark stars have
become active
they've won return and to begun
initiating their campaigns and much like
the green lanterns which we'll see here
in a little bit the dark stars can
actually bring people to their cause
they can make they can turn them into
dark stars and so we're Barry Allen
shows up initially you know it's a cool
conversation between the two because one
of the things that Hal Jordan has been
suffering from and this is something
that I think that Venditti and them are
really kind of moving cool and I'm
moving backwards is that how Jordan
might become parallax again and the
reason why is because he's had a lot of
negative thoughts when it's come to his
role as a superhero when it's come to
the various supervillains that are out
there and one of the big things he's
talked about is is it really a bad thing
if we kill people who commit crimes a
dead man can't be a repeat offender it's
an extreme perception but there is some
some legitimacy and merit to it and so
in response to this you know Barry Allen
kind of talks him down a little bit but
this has been an ongoing theme with Hal
Jordan since the events of Dark Knight's
metal and even before that Hal Jordan
has routinely seen death and destruction
over and over and over again and the
question he has to ask is what's the
point of being a cop if we're always
late would it really be a bad thing to
stop the crimes before they happen and
it's one of the things that he says -
how I get where you're coming from but
these thoughts can't lead anywhere but
bad it could lead you back to that dark
place that you were before and Hal
Jordans response is yeah but that might
not be the worst thing and so it's it's
it's interesting here it's a great
exchange between the two it's one of the
reasons why the flash and Hal Jordan
have always bounced off each other so
well in terms of how they were written
because they're the character
interactions between the two not really
the battle
they fight alongside in or anything like
that but the conversations between the
two or what makes them so interesting
and so picking up with Guy Gardner we
end up having guys show up to a bar only
to be met by arkillo
now again for those of you guys who were
playing a little bit of catch-up here if
you saw my previous videos arkillo was a
long-standing member of the Sinestro
Corps for a very very long time one of
its very first members and so where he
had gone through and routinely been a
bad guy as Geoff Johns run you know
basically reached its conclusion or at
least when he was writing it and then
Robert Venditti took over and then DC
rebirth happened we started to see this
kind of shift between the two most
notably we saw where the Sinestro Corps
and the Green Lantern Corps teamed up
and where there was a lot of bitterness
and anger between the two groups for
arkillo and Guy Gardner they actually
became close friends to this whole thing
between the two this is really what kind
of boils down to like a back-alley deal
they're really not supposed to be
meeting with each other for the Green
Lantern's they don't really mind but for
the Sinestro Corps it's you do not meet
with Green Lantern's you do not
associate with them talk to them if you
see one you kill them but with Guy
Gardner and arkillo talking to each
other Guy Gardner basically says look
man there's a much bigger threat out
there the dark stars are rising and the
dark stars do not have a moral compass
they don't believe in truth and justice
or any of that stuff they believe that
if you commit a crime you're guilty and
you're done and that's it and so it's
it's it's extreme it's it's really
heavy-handed and that's kind of what Guy
Gardner says because of what's going on
with the dark stars rising there's
essentially this point now where the
Green Lantern's are sending out what
amounts to an SOS every single Ally
that's out there they are running and
they are grabbing except for the ones
based on earth for the most part but you
have Kyle Rayner transition to him where
he meets up with cabby now again cabby
is basically the Han Solo of the DC
Universe it's really what he is and it's
cool but one of the things that's
happened here is that he's basically
modified his ship because he would
travel throughout the known universe and
he was basically a guy that would get
people to places where they weren't
supposed to be or get them through like
back channels and so on and so forth but
for what Guy Gardner needs they have to
leave the current universe and so what's
happened here is cabbie has basically
brought a mother box essentially on the
black market which would allow him to
leave the universe and travel to the
realm of the new gods and that's exactly
what happens what they end up doing is
traveling directly to where the new gods
are located on now of course again kind
of transitioning from there we pick up
with Jon Stewart in what's probably one
of the greatest moments ever when he
shows up here he shows up to basically
gain the aid of General Zod which is a
different
thing to do but the funny thing about
this is that we're Zod immediately goes
to attack Jon Stewart cracks him in the
hand with brass knuckles and initially
it seems like the brass knuckles are
made out of a hard like construct but
they're not they're actually brass
knuckles made of kryptonite now that's
just the most boss ass thing I've ever
heard of it's beast like using brass
knuckles made of Kryptonite it's like
one of the coolest things ever it's like
this genius idea and so it's basically
John Stewart saying hey look man do I
have your attention now because we need
to have a conversation you know I've got
kryptonite here so if I bring a close
enough it's only a matter of time before
you die so either we can talk or you can
die from here or we transition over to
basically striker Island penitentiary
and we end up picking up with Hector
Hammond now Hector Hammond has been a
background character in the Green
Lantern stories for quite some time and
the reason why was because he played a
very significant role when it came to
like the War of the Green Lanterns them
and things like that
brightest day so on and so forth and so
because of that it was really I imagined
a desire of entity to break away from
the quote unquote traditional villains
of the Green Lantern mythos and start
focusing on other things and so for the
most part Hector Hammond is just kind of
been in the background the whole time
just sort of sitting in strikers Island
but with Hal Jordan showing up here what
it means is that times are dire because
Hector Hammonds not a guy that you just
trifle with he's not a guy you just wake
up and we'll find out why here a little
bit because what ends up happening is
basically how Jordan is met by the
arrival of atomic skull now atomic skull
has been the name of a couple different
people but the most notable one and the
one that's this here is Joseph Morgan
the reason why I say the most notable is
because that's essentially the most
popular one post-crisis when it comes to
Joseph Martin he is a guy really who's
whose strength durability is really on
par with like Superman like he's really
really capable but the way he grew he
gained his powers was from the
dominators storyline back in the
post-crisis landscapes which was then
activating the gene bomb it was DC's
attempt to sort of quote-unquote create
a mutant concept the gene bomb was a way
for DC to basically kind of Usher in
this huge explosion of powers into the
DC Universe landscape and then just kind
of pick and choose who got to have what
and and try to build up heroes and
villains from there that's really where
atomic school comes from but again
transitioning back over we end up having
this Green Lantern who's basically
traveling to their destination and this
is really just Venditti showing us how
extreme the dark stars are because when
this Green Lantern is transporting a guy
who's guilty of murder the Green Lantern
basically tells the dark stars look you
guys got to get out of here you're
pretenders you guys have no idea what
you're doing
at which point this guy is basically
blown to
the prisoner himself is completely
destroyed and that's the end of this guy
so it's really designed to say like the
dark stars are pretty lethal now of
course with atomic skull facing off
against hazard not a whole lot doing
here it's just kind of atomic school
doing what atomic school does he's
essentially a good guy now he's
basically a warden for the prison and
you know keeping control of the inmates
but of course where it looks like he's
gonna get the better half of or I guess
get the upper hand on on Hal Jordan
Hector Hammond wakes up and essentially
like shuts down the mind of atomic skull
and that's really the end of him and so
again it's kind of a cool thing but it's
basically this idea that like Jon
Stewart old some pretty underhanded
things because switching switching back
to him this is one of the important
things about Jon Stewart for the most
part before he became leader of the
Green Lantern Corps Jon Stewart was in a
lot of ways by the book now it didn't
mean he never broke the rules
but it does mean that for the most part
he followed the rules but becoming
leader of the Green Lantern Corps means
that sometimes you have to come to the
realization that some rules are meant to
be bent and others can be broken to
quote the matrix and so with this whole
thing he basically approaches Zod and
says look we know you hate Green
Lantern's you blame Green Lantern's for
the destruction of Krypton you asked the
question where was it where was
Krypton's Green Lantern when the planet
was destroyed and that's a valid
question
tomar Rey was nowhere to be found you
can't take your vengeance on tomar Rey
because he's dead so you take your
vengeance on the entire Green Lantern
Corps but what if I told you you could
have your vengeance on tomar too now on
the surface it seems kind of like well I
mean it's par for the course but when
you're someone like Jon Stewart who is
for the most part honor duty and loyalty
first it's one of these things where he
sort of betrays a bit of Honor he just
kind of cast that aside for a second but
it's a small sacrifice for a much bigger
win and it was really necessary here I
mean things are just that drastic and
that's what this is designed to show
it's designed to show how drastic things
are that Jon Stewart would take this
step and so ultimately he gains the
attention of General Zod who says okay
let's let's have this conversation let's
let's sit down and let's talk and let's
see what's going on and so at this one
where we switch back over to our kylo
and end guy Gardner and they're
basically met with the arrival of the
dark stars basically tomar tomar - and
the dark stars no it's kind of cool
because this is how the dark stars
swindle people - their path the dark
stars base desire is it's almost primal
imagine a modified Red Lantern ring it's
kind of how this scenes with a Red
Lantern ring when you're when you're
chosen when this is like you know you
have great rage in your heart you belong
to the Red Lanterns and the ring bonds
itself to you all this really means is
that you just kind of revert to a very
primal state
and all you do is just take orders with
the dark stars you're still capable in
Retton and you're so capable of rational
thought but you've been to your own
extreme desires and that really kind of
complements the purpose of the dark
stars which is to eliminate everybody
who commits murder to have no real
inhibitions about taking life of those
you deemed to be guilty and so with Guy
Gardner himself he's approached by tomar
- who says look we both came from bad
situations and we've we've both dealt
with this shame of our fathers in a lot
of different ways so I give you the
opportunity would you like to take
revenge on your father for what he's
done and guard Garner's response is yes
and so this is when he's immediately
bonded with the Dark Star EXO mantle
basically and is made into one of their
group so again guy Gardner is the first
Green Lantern to fall prey to the dark
stars now of course with Hector Hammond
and and and Hal Jordan they essentially
just kind of like race off you know it's
and it's kind of cool because when it
comes to Hector Hammond he'd always
idolized Hal Jordan right I mean that
was one that was one of the funny things
about his character is that when Hector
Hammond first met Hal Jordan he
considered him to be just somewhat of a
goof really once Hector realized he was
the Green Lantern it was always Hector
sort of chasing after him trying to be
the hero that Hal Jordan was because in
the mind of Hector it was the heroes get
the girls the heroes of the brave guys
they get the adoration they get the fame
they get all that kind of stuff I want
that so I should be a hero but it was
particular attention to Hal Jordan
himself and so that's why you know
Hector Hammond has always kind of been
like the ultimate fan even if a little
bit extreme and a little bit you know
weird in terms of how he doesn't he's
always kind of been the ultimate fan and
so that's why you see he's along for the
ride but he kind of celebrates the
chance to face off alongside Hal Jordan
now house warren is not too happy about
it you know it's just something that he
needs to do because of the power Hector
Hammond has with his telepathic
abilities having been enhanced recently
and so again picking up with a father of
Guy Gardner with Roland Gardner this is
actually interesting because Guy Gardner
shows up and says rolling Gardner you
know you used to be the crap out of me
your penalty is death and this is
intense because Guy Gardner has just
kind of fallen down to his darker side
so again switching back to Hector and
and Hal Jordan this is this is a really
really awesome exchange here because
what happens is Hector basically starts
talking to howl and says look I can do
anything with my powers like like
anything that you want me to do I can
basically create all manner of illusions
and this instance he shows how Jordan
all of the villains in the DC Universe
who have all been killed by Hector
Hammond and Hal Jordan kind of freaks
out about that
says this is ridiculous I don't want to
do anything like that and Hector's
response is yes you do I've read your
mind this is what you truly want no no
this is not Hector Hammond being
manipulative at the moment this is the
most visceral and real thing that Hal
Jordan feels Hal Jordan wants to see the
death of all the villains on a base
level Hal Jordan becoming parallax is
only a matter of time because he's
falling back down to this path of just
darkness and doing whatever it takes to
win and so when House says look you
don't know what you're talking about
none of this is true Hector says I
always listen I hear everything just
because I'm unconscious doesn't mean my
brain is unconscious I hear everything
that goes on and it kind of flashes back
to the conversation that Hal Jordan had
with Superman at the end of dark nights
metal when he when he when he talks to
him it says maybe it wouldn't be the
worst thing to destroy all the villains
like I could kill Hector Hammond right
now and what anybody really care again
that darkness is showing itself that
darker side of Hal Jordan is kind of
coming back and so Hector's response is
don't worry how I will fix everything I
will make everything okay I will take
care of all the villains for you and you
won't have any blood on your hands all I
need for you to do is to stay out of the
way
and he does this by wiping the mind of
Hal Jordan to where Hal Jordan doesn't
remember anything about himself doesn't
know his name doesn't know his power or
anything his mind is completely and
totally white and it's just like wow I
mean it's it's crazy to see that happen
now the other half of this is that with
the dark stars themselves one of the
things that they do is they basically
teleport in and teleport out and so this
makes them exceedingly difficult to
catch no one really knows exactly where
they're going to but just to say they
don't know if they're teleporting to a
location to one planet to take care of
somebody and then teleporting to another
planet and there's a lot of space out
there the only way to really be able to
know where they're going is to have a
Green Lantern set at every single planet
in every single star system across the
entire universe in every single galaxy
which is impossible it's absolutely
unreasonable to try to do that it would
require massive like it's just an
astronomical number of beings in order
to make that happen
and so in response to this what ends up
happening is Jon Stewart hits up do you
know how General Zod it says look what
do you know about teleportation
disrupting technology and when it comes
to Zod he says well like most other
things in Krypton they were lost a time
but it would take weeks I mean we can
recreate one but it would take a long
time and Jon Stewart's response is I was
an architect Homeslice just wait and
watch what I do and it's the coolest
thing he did he basically recreates the
whole thing using using Green Lantern
tech and it's cool like it's it's pretty
badass to see
but Joey back to Guy Gardner here one of
the cool things is that where he I mean
not really cool that he's getting ready
to you know kill his dad or kill Oh
flies in and basically stops him now
this is not arkillo looking for a tried
and true fight he's doing this as a
friend you know he's he's stepping in
it's like it's like punching a drunk
friend in the face and order to get them
to calm down and keep them from doing
something stupid that's what it's full
stances here you do not want to kill
your pops you think you do and this dark
star energy is telling you to but you
don't really want to because if you do
this the instant it happens you're gonna
regret it you're going to have crossed a
line that you can't come back from and
it is my duty as your friend to keep you
from crossing that line now the fight
between the two is pretty knocked down
and dragged out because it's our killer
really fighting more on a defensive side
and Guy Gardner fighting more on the
offense of course the reason why with
our killer fighting defenses because
he's not looking to kill Guy Gardner
he's looking to incapacitate him to
defeat him but because of the fact that
it's really our killer fighting fighting
in a defensive way it's him trying to
reason with God one of the things he
says here is look there was a time when
I was beyond redemption I murdered I I
did all manner of things that simply did
nothing more than make me happy and the
Sinestro Corps you know basically fed
into that it gave me the ability did to
instill fear across the universe which
made me one of the most feared beings in
the entirety of the universe and I kept
doing what I do only doing it with more
power but you guy Gardner showed me a
better way he showed me a better path
and your father deserved that same
Redemption your father deserves the
chance to be seen to be shown a better
path if he hasn't found it already but
if you really believe that that all this
was a waste if you really believed that
I is arkillo in the am incapable of
being redeemed if you really believe
that I'm putting on an act
but I'm faking it that none of this is
true then kill your father but if you
truly believe that I am a good guy if
you truly believe that I have redeemed
myself then you have to believe your
father can too and Dad that that right
there hits right in the fields gets Guy
Gardner right in the fields and what he
does is it amps up his his willpower and
overpowers the Darkstar excellent mantel
so this is one of the cool caveat said
then dead he puts in here if a green
lantern has enough willpower they can
override the dark star X no mantle it's
so basically a way of saying it's there
it's there escape now what it also means
is it takes a lot of willpower it's
awesome to see this unfold now of course
this leads to kind of a quick goodbye
hey pop sorry for killing you we'll grab
a cup of a cup of coffee when I get back
push like it's basically him bailing out
this essentially hint that's kind of
taken off and so jumping over here you
know to me back to Hal Jordan again this
is why things are so cool because Hal
Jordan as he's trying to figure out who
he is as he feels confused he's met by
this sort of disembodied voice that says
do not listen to Hector Hammond ignore
Hector Hammond he's duping you he's
lying to you this is what he does and as
is as Hector Hammond tries to combat
this voice this voice keeps getting
stronger and stronger and stronger and
this is when we end up finding out this
planet they've been on is a planet where
Hal Jordan forged his own ring now this
is important because this happened at
the very beginning of green lantern
rebirth Hal Jordan was basically a
renegade he was an outcast he had taken
the fall for the Green Lantern Corps and
essentially said like I'm the reason
they did all these these things and so
on and so forth but the fact remains
what ended up happening is like no other
Green Lantern ever done before him what
he managed to do who was forge a ring
out of his own willpower his willpower
was so strong he forged a ring out of it
I mean it would be like you really
needing a pencil and just fabricating
one out of thin air out of your need to
have one like it's it's that's exactly
what he did and so because of this his
willpower in this planet is inherently
strong this planet is part and parcel to
him and so his willpower is dormant here
it lays here and that's what his
willpower says the reason why we brought
Hector ham into this world is because we
knew he would try to mess with our mind
and we needed to be in a place where our
willpower was so extreme that we could
overcome insurmountable odds and so
how's Jordan basically REME urges with
his own willpower regains every ounce of
himself and then of course Hector
Hammond reveals what's truly going on
with Hector being here
what he says is these beans that you're
facing off against these dark stars do
not care about right and wrong they
don't care about moral compasses they
don't care about how you define truth
and justice all they care about is that
a person committed a crime that person
has to die and when you're facing off
against them you're gonna be met with
your own worst demons your own worst
fears you're gonna be met with all these
parts of yourself they're gonna think
have long since been lost and they
weren't they were there all the time
you just never dealt with him you had to
face your own fear this was Hector
Hammond helping out Hal Jordan in a very
very very big way a very important way
because what it means now is that Hal
Jordan is stronger with his willpower it
means that he knows what to expect in
this fight against the dark stars and he
won't really be taken by surprise and
what what the Hector kind of says here
is that it's not the things that you
that you believe it's not your moral
compass or anything like that
the defined he was a hero it's what you
do just because you believe that people
should be saved doesn't mean you'll save
them it's the belief you'll save them
and then actually going out and saving
them that makes you a hero that's what
makes you who you are and it's the only
thing that matters you cast aside these
darker feelings you cast aside this idea
that people who all committed crimes
should basically be eliminated and so
he's kind of one step away from parallax
now notice this then Danny doesn't say
he'll never become parallax he's just
kind of a step away from where he was
before as it was kind of a cool thing
but in the middle of all this we end up
Tranio transitioning back to Moga with
Kilowog who basically sounds the SOS
because the dark stars have vintage
hacking the Green Lantern's everywhere
they find them and so in this instance
Kilowog kind of says okay weed everybody
to come back here and the reason why is
because the dark stars have surrounded
the entire planet of Mogo and if given
the ability to do so they will destroy
everyone here but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here two comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]